wanna be happy live a life not just a
[Music]
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you
back a lack of belief in yourself you
watch these videos because you
know you're capable of more you have
michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn
what every overweight person needs to
hear
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one push yourself to
change with mel robbins there are two
things that i want you to do
i want you to narrow your focus down to
the literally minute to minute decisions
that you're making about your health
don't think big picture get through
today
second thing i want you to do i want you
to use the five second rule the way that
you're going to use it is if you
have a diet the diet is very
straightforward
it's black and white there's a list of
things you're allowed to eat and a
ton of things that you're not allowed to
eat so the diet itself
is very straightforward and simple but
the reason why dieting isn't
easy is because of how you feel about
dieting
dieting itself is simple the reason why
it's hard
is because you listen to how you feel i
want you to go through an exercise
where you write down all of the triggers
that make you eat do you
like to eat after you've had breakfast
like you like a little snack on the way
to work
do you like to eat when you feel
vulnerable do you like to eat at five
o'clock in the afternoon do you like to
eat when you feel bored do you like to
eat when you're sitting in front of the
tv
do you like to eat after dinner do you
sample everything off of your kids
plates
if you've got kids like identify all
those areas
where you fall into the trap of of not
following your diet
now what i want you to do is to use a
piece of research that has
proven over and over and over again in
an experiment after experiment after
experiment that will make you
three times more likely to stick to your
diet you ready it's called
if then planning so
i had to make a list of all those places
where you're
you're you're probably gonna cheat right
where you start to feel a certain way
you feel defeated you feel tired you
feel bored you feel pissed off at your
boss
you're not really thinking so you're
shoving food in your mouth now what
you're going to do is you're going to
take that list of things that trigger
you to cheat on your diet
and you're going to use if then planning
and how it works is this
you're going to say if i feel tired
then what are you going to do because
right now what you're doing is you're
eating
if i feel tired then i'm going to stand
up and go for a walk around the house
if i feel bored then i'm going to stand
up and walk into the kitchen
and i'm going to allow myself to surf
online and check out facebook for five
minutes instead of eating
if i feel stressed out or i feel like i
can't do it anymore
then i'm going to call a friend the
reason why you want to do this
is because first of all you've told the
truth to yourself about all the ways
that you cheat
and all the things that trigger you to
overeat and not stick to your diet
and secondly you stuck something in
place that is your plan b
so that you're not subject to your
emotions in the moment
so here we go you're vulnerable because
you're focused on the gap between where
you are and the future you
so first things first let's narrow the
focus and let's focus
day to day moment to moment
on what you're doing second you're gonna
use the five second rule
the moment you feel yourself cheating on
your diet or being drawn toward food you
shouldn't be eating
count backwards five four three two one
that will quiet all of the garbage in
your mind
it will awaken your prefrontal cortex
and it will
point you toward your goal which is
sticking to that damn diet
and finally i want you to do an
assessment and identify
all the ways in which and things that
trigger you
to overeat and cheat on your diet and
then i want you to come up
with an if then if i feel this if i see
this
if i catch myself doing this then i'm
gonna pick up the phone or i'm gonna go
for a walk or i'm gonna surf facebook
i'm gonna do something
other than cheat on my diet
try those things let us know how it goes
and most of all we want you to know
we're really proud of you for taking it
on
because it takes a lot of courage to
face the things that aren't working in
your life
and to push yourself to change it rule
number two do the mental work with drew
manning
transformation is so much more mental
and emotional than people think and if
you've never been overweight
mostly what you can relate to is the
physical side of weight loss right eat
less and work out
you know that right you got that you've
lived that but the mental emotional side
you haven't lived that until you've kind
of been down this path and so for me my
eyes were opened
i realized just how wrong i was with
trying to help people right
and did you mean your strategies were
actually bad because you didn't
understand the men they weren't bad
they were just incomplete they were just
focused on the physical so if someone
was struggling with
their transformation i'm like okay let's
change up your macros change up your
calories change up your workouts
that's the missing component right
that's what i i focus on because that's
all i knew
rather than trying to help them on the
mental emotional side which is what
people struggle with right i think
people
it's not so much a lack of knowledge
right people know they need to eat
healthy and work out
it's it's the application on the mental
emotional side and the consistency of
living that lifestyle over
over time and that's where people
struggle is is maintaining as a
lifestyle change which is more up here
than it is in the gym or in the kitchen
so i want to
really define what you mean by mental
and emotional
so what is it that people are struggling
with an attachment to
food the emotional reward of eating like
what is it
yeah and it's different for each person
the thing that i realized was
was how powerful the emotional
connection to food really is whereas
before i'm like look it's not that hard
you just
you know you stop eating the junk food
put down the soda you go to the gym
every day
what's wrong like it's not that hard
until i lived it
even even though it was only for just
six months when i
switched and tried to lose the weight
that emotional connection to food was
way more powerful even for me as a
trainer someone who lived their whole
life healthy
and my body went through those
withdrawal symptoms right almost like a
drug addict
i won't say i was addicted some people
are truly addicted but for me
just being aware of how powerful that
emotional connection to food really is
what do you do when you have cravings or
you know when you when you eat your
emotions when you're
sad or you're happy we celebrate or we
had a stressful day so we're like you
know what i deserve wine and chocolate
tonight because i had a stressful day
so how do you help people through that
so i grew up in a morbidly obese family
so i
i know exactly how people can find
comfort and or celebration in food how
do you help them
dive into that like do you get like
psychological and
and actually almost like a therapist
walk them through that stuff so
there's obviously a physical component
of transformation so that you help them
with the physical side but i think you
know it's like 10
that 90 help them with the mental
emotional side and how i do that
is putting them in support groups right
so it's not just me because
i'm still a fit guy it's putting them in
a support group where they
it's a safe place for them to share
their struggles their successes their
failures
and receive that encouragement and the
empathy that love
and that people letting them know that
they're worth it to continue to fight
for their health
rule number three try intermittent
fasting with dr steven gundry
let's suppose your design is that you
only get so many calories in your
lifetime
and you can use them quickly or you can
spread them out
and that's why that's why fasting
is so useful and intermittent fasting is
so useful
because it's actually an easy way
just to reduce your calorie intake
and it's you know once you learn how to
do it
it's it's an easy way to make the system
work
how do you pull it off so i'm a huge
proponent of intermittent fasting and
fasting in general how do you do how do
you make it an easy process
so i started 11 years ago
at january 1st to june 1st
during the week i would eat all my
calories in a two-hour window from
six to eight o'clock at night so that 22
out of the 24 hours
every day five days a week i was fasting
22 hours now why six to eight o'clock at
night
because that's when my wife and i were
at home and
now this is as you know for a
professional driver on a closed course
what most people who try to do this
don't realize
about 80 percent of us in america
are insulin resistant we have much too
much
insulin production and i won't bore
you or the listeners but most people
can't do prolonged fasting for even more
than a few hours
because they can't access the fat that
they store
and they crash and it's often called the
atkins flu or the low carb flu
where they have to be able to transition
over to
using ketones as a fuel now you can get
there fairly quickly and we have tips in
the book on how to do that
you actually have to use exogenous
ketones for a while
things like mct oil things like coconut
oil
even red palm oil there's a little bit
of exogenous ketones in butter
it's called butyric acid yeah it's
intermittent fasting is really really
powerful for
alleviating brain fog for changing a
relationship to hunger is how i always
think of it it's just fundamentally
different
and then getting your machinery used to
actually accessing your body fat and all
that
we're designed to use up fat we just
have to
you know use the tricks to get to that
fat for
most people who are overweight or obese
what's so frustrating for them is they
try
things like intermittent fasting and
they're pretty miserable they get
headaches and
they're very hungry the brain is going
hey you know what what's the deal you've
cut me off
it's water water everywhere and not a
drop
to drink and we see so many
overweight and obese people and i was 70
pounds overweight i was obese
running 30 miles a week and going to the
gym one hour a day and going well how
come i'm such a fat guy
i couldn't get to my fat stores because
i had an elevated insulin level
when i first you know got my insulin was
wow
um what's that now i have a very low
insulin
now that stuff is fascinating in terms
of the complexities of really breaking
through and figuring out
for you what do you have to do to lose
fat keep it off and
yeah it's a very complex thing also if
you want to have more confident self
love and motivation check out my 254
series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below i know that
everybody's problem comes down to one
pattern you're repeating that you can't
see
it's good to treat other people the way
you would like to be treated yourself
it's like a
golden rule and there's a reason for it
and that reason is that we're connected
you can outwork anybody how badass they
are
rule number four eat healthy with joe
rogan i would say
if i was you what i would get down to is
i would say definitely
start eating a lot of vegetables there's
that's pretty much universal
everybody agrees except these crazy
carnivore people but i think their
situation is like either an elimination
diet or a calorie restricted diet which
is not really the best for performance i
don't think for the kind of
you're trying to do yeah i think
broccoli
kale spinach all that stuff sauteed all
that stuff's fantastic for you then on
top of that
i mean obviously i eat red meat i'm a
big fan of red meat i think you should
eat
just like very nutrient dense meat
and i think you should take
multivitamins just to cover all your
bases
you know there's a bunch of like really
good green supplements that you can add
to water
or you know little packets you could
take you count your calories no
so you just eat until you're full yeah
really yeah how many calories do you
think you eat a day
i really don't know like if you had to
guess what elk is pretty lean
yeah it's pretty lean and you looks like
you're eating maybe eight ounces of elk
i probably eat a pound of that a day for
sure
at least yeah i mean i you shoot one you
have 400 pounds of meat
i have some for you if you want i
definitely do i got a bunch of sausage
elk sausage is sensational really
i love it you'll love it a ton of it man
i'm definitely up for that yeah okay
i got a bunch in the back okay i got
these freezer bags too you could take it
home with
um i would say just cut out the sugar
and the bread and the pasta and if you
just do that you'll lose a ton of weight
you lose a ton of weight just doing that
i mean this one's gonna be
awesome yeah man just vegetables just
eat a you know get yourself a
big bowl of broccolini and cook it with
butter and
olive oil and put garlic salt on it it's
healthy it feels good when you eat it
your body responds well to it
you know just only good nutrients man
and just realize you're gonna have to
get a lot of rest and you're gonna have
to drink a
ton of water and rule number five the
last one before a very special bonus
clip
is make sacrifices with david goggins
so i finally met a guy named steven
saljo i caught him on the phone
after about two weeks of just hunting
down recruiters
and he was a navy reservist recruiter
so i called him up i said hey i want to
be a navy seal he was busy
so he didn't know how big i was he
didn't know anything about me pretty
much
so i came in and he was the first
recruiter that looked at me was like
you know he saw how big i was but he
gave me a shot
okay and i was just looking for a shot
so it kind of went from there
he went through all different you know
manuals and to make a long story short i
had to lose
106 pounds in less than three months
and that's where it became challenging
for me
so how did you go about losing that
weight in three months like what
what was your training slash dieting
plan at that point well there wasn't
much of a
of a diet pretty much as i pretty much
don't eat
and what i did was i wake up in the
morning time i'd have a banana
so i knew to lose 106 pounds in less
than three months
looking at 3 500 calories is a pound
so i was basically doing a whole bunch
of math in my
head so i knew if i were to stop
and be stagnant there was no calories
being burned
so my mind became very obsessed
so if i'd like like right now i couldn't
have this interview
i'd have to do it while riding a bike so
to watch tv
i rode a bike because you know weighing
300 pounds you know you can't go out and
start running
because your legs hurt real bad so for
the first 50 days
i rode a bike a lot i went to the
swimming pool a lot
i did high repetitions so people go you
know why don't i have like a lot of fat
like excess skin on my body
i develop a certain routine that my skin
got you know
extremely tight so i would do 100 200
300 400 500 reps
on one exercise at a time so i would go
to the gym
i would see a weight i could do for like
let's say it was like
60 pounds on the bar that's also
so the bar is 45 and i put like maybe 10
pounds on each side
and i would rep that out for like a
hundred times
and i'll do a few sets of that and
that's how i would train
so i i was basically trained all day
long
so that's how i went and before i knew
it
i lost the weight now i've got a really
special bonus clip that i think you're
gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you
going to do to take action on it this
week when you write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following
through even higher so that's what i
want to do today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what is your
plan to take action on it
this week let me know put it down in the
comments below
growing up i never had to worry about my
weight i was always a pretty skinny kid
i was 6'1
i weighed 165 pounds i was at the lower
level of just
barely being healthy according those bmi
charts and so i could eat whatever i
want
pretty active kid but then growing up as
you get into your 30s
you know the weight starts adding up
especially for entrepreneurs living a
busy lifestyle
and i quickly found myself to being
almost 200 pounds
and so i decided i got to get my act
together i gotta lose some weight some
of you guys have been uh
commenting and noticing thank you for
the love and so in today's video i'm
gonna share with you the seven ways that
i use to lose 19 and a half pounds
in one month
so way number one is i would fast until
noon and fasting for me would be liquids
only and really that's just
water lots of water here and
coffee now this probably wasn't the
healthiest part i would have two of
these
that would last me from whenever i woke
up usually around seven ish until
12 o'clock one o'clock and this is an
extra large
two milk one sugar from tim hortons so
having two extra large coffees
probably wasn't the healthiest choice in
the morning but i found that one the
caffeine really helped curb the appetite
and i found if i delayed my eating until
the afternoon then i could consume the
calories that i needed in the afternoon
and not get started too early
i found when i started eating too early
then
then i just kept eating all day long and
i found it difficult to kind of stay
on the diet it's 11 55.
decisions what am i gonna order what am
i gonna eat
and so fast into noon only water and
coffee and then we eat my first meal at
noon
at the earliest sometimes 1 or even 1
30.
way number two is 30 minutes of cardio
every day what i found the easiest thing
to do was actually just
at night at nine o'clock i would set a
routine that my wife and i would usually
watch something on tv some show
we'd watch arrow or billions or
what else do we watch arrow billions
some gotham blind spot
we mix between the shows we sit down at
nine nine o'clock
and i would run on the spot at nine
o'clock so just be like
while we're watching the show i'd be
like this i'd be running running running
for half an hour
after that i do some stretching and
usually those shows with no commercials
go about 40-ish minutes 42 minutes
so it's the perfect time so i knew nine
o'clock
watch the show half an hour running 10
to 12 minutes of stretching afterwards
it was the perfect setting and then have
a shower and get ready for bed
i've since suggested it just recently
where i do a morning run
instead i usually run to the local whole
foods
that's about 15 minutes away then pick
up a kombucha some salad bananas maybe
and come back
but for most of that weight loss journey
it was a nine o'clock
30 minute run and i did that every
single day of the week
way number three is i use the seinfeld
technique and the seinfeld technique is
to
print a calendar for the year so here's
mine my calendar for the year and
basically every single day you want to
mark it off with an x on the calendar
when you've done that thing and so for
me the two things i was tracking
was running 30 minutes a day and fast
until noon if i did that i would get an
x and so the goal is to not break the
chain
and so every single day i would get my x
and you can see here
i started it this just before my may
21st date so may
21st is what here somewhere
and up until june 21st which is today
it's not quite noon filming this yet so
i can't mark it off
but that really helped just kind of stay
on track and you'd like to see the
progress
and when you see those x's coming on you
don't want to break the chain so you
want to keep going every day
[Music]
way number four was i used saturday as a
cheat day and that was when i could eat
whatever i wanted
you know there was no calorie
restrictions at just eight eight eight
eight
eight but i still had to keep my chain
so i still was
running for 30 minutes in the day and i
was still fasting until noon this was
one of the hardest things because i get
this
delicious donut from tim hortons or this
breakfast
that ends at noon and so i really wanted
to eat that so he buy it a couple
minutes early i'd be sitting there
looking at my donut like i got five
minutes left before i can eat this thing
and then once noon came like
shove it in so saturday is my cheat day
but i still
am on my fast until noon it's 15 minutes
till noon
and i'm excited to dig into my boston
cream donut
this is gonna be a brutal 15 minutes i
love it
so that really helped it helps it helps
on a psychological level to have one day
when you can eat whatever you want
and i think there's also a lot of
research that backs up having a cheat
day to kind of spike your levels and
then come back down can actually
facilitate more weight loss as well and
so i found that really helpful
but i kept to my fasting until noon and
running 30 minutes a day
guys when you persevere and it's hard
and you make it through
and you win the victory is just so much
sweeter
[Music]
oh my god so good
way number five was no packaged foods
and so i made a decision apart from the
coffee that would happen in the morning
i wouldn't need anything from a package
so nothing with a wrapper nothing
uh store-bought that was not just
processed but even healthy stuff i
wouldn't eat from a wrapper so i always
eat protein bars before
and just other things from the package i
decided nope not gonna do that anymore
and most of my diet consists of fish
we don't really eat a lot of meat except
on saturdays just fish and vegetables
fish vegetables nuts mostly assortment
of whitefish
cod different fillets haddock
walleye bunch of stuff nina's been
fantastic in helping
kind of prepare all the foods and it's
great having a partner on this journey
so she's eaten basically the same stuff
i am
and then broccoli and cabbage and green
beans and sugar snap peas and
it's basically pretty easy to get filled
up because you're only really eating two
big meals a day uh i would start usually
at noon eating a banana
or two bananas probably two bananas
sometimes three bananas in a day
and then into my lunch and then into my
dinner and that would be it
i would snack on nuts um and everything
basically
not from a package trying to trying to
stay healthy try to stay clean and it's
really helped with the weight loss
[Music]
way number six is use myfitnesspal
myfitnesspal is an app that allows you
to track
your calories and i'll load it up here
to show you guys
so what you can do is put in the foods
can you see can you see can you see
anyway what you can do is you they have
goals this is a free app that's put out
by under armour
i think it's under armour you can put in
your goals of how high you are
like how high you are you pick how tall
you are what your goal is for weight and
how quickly you want to achieve it and
it'll give you a calorie target
and then you can enter in your food and
it gives you a sense of
what every single meal looks like and so
if you're eating an avocado you might
think that's really healthy but has
a lot of calories and so just being able
to balance it out if you are educated to
know
what is in your food there are days that
i will go to i will go to tim hortons
and get a crispy chicken sandwich which
is
fried chicken uh and bread and you know
fairly high calories like 540 calories
something like that
but it fits it fits within my day and so
just educating yourself on how many
calories are in each meal
is great it has a barcode scanner so if
you are eating out then
you can easily find most of the foods at
the major chains
if you are anything from a package you
can barcode scan it and it will tell you
the nutritional breakdown on it and
it'll tell you how much you should be
eating in terms of protein
fat and carbohydrates and then you can
see am i matching up
i think the biggest thing for me was
just recognizing the difference
in the foods and educating myself so i
could eat more properly and match
my intake to where i should be and so
why we do a lot of fish
is because it's insanely high protein so
you get your protein targets easily
and not a lot of calories and so if
you're eating that it's a lot easier to
fill up your day with other stuff that
you want to eat because you're hitting
your targets at a really low calorie
level so i would highly recommend
checking out
myfitnesspal free to use and there's a
premium program that you can upgrade to
i don't use it
but you can and it'll help you on your
journey
[Music]
and way number seven this is the most
recent thing that i'm doing i'm trying
to substitute
out coffee for kombucha and so kombucha
is
supposed to be super healthy full of
probiotics got some got a whole bunch of
stuff floating around in it and i do my
morning run to whole foods pick up a
kombucha i am now between
one kombucha and no coffees to to one
coffee a day and i'm slowly
starting to substitute out the coffee
for kombucha
during the week the coffee is the only
thing really in my diet
apart from saturday that that is junky
that is not healthy that is from a box
that is packaged
and so i want to slowly reduce that and
replace it with the kombucha
and then on weekends saturday saturday
only
eat whatever i want and so those are the
seven things that's really helped me
on my weight loss journey again at the
beginning
i never thought i had to worry about it
growing up was always super skinny and
always healthy
and at some point life catches up with
you and you got to decide to invest in
yourself
and be healthy
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days
check the link right here below me or if
you want to know the six habits you have
to adopt if you want to stay healthy
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe
and i'll see you there